anyway so let's talk about what happened
in beverly hills kai you want to pull up
the video
so apparently beverly hills
has a is becoming a hub for conservative
rallies go up a little bit go up a
little bit with the article to read the
main
point to the article how did beverly
hills become a hub for conservative
rallies
so they're going out there protesting in
beverly hills
90210 rodeo drive and this is what just
happened a couple days ago go down and
click on that video
there you go click on the video and you
can make it a little bigger
they go make it bigger and hit the audio
so we can hear it kai
watch this listen to that this is
beverly hills
did you hear that
[Applause]
oh
looks like the jerry springer show wow
yeah that's you're talking about beverly
hills
one of the most expensive real estates
look at this
wanting to trash the american flag
dropping the american flag
oh they got weapons too
[Music]
where's taggart from beverly hills cop
when you need him he's been in there
breaking that up
you know it makes sense that they're
doing those protests there because it's
you know you got the backdrop they're
doing it right on santa monica boulevard
right by the iconic you know fountains
and the beverly hills sign and
so you're going to get attention you're
going to get the cameras you're going to
get the the
dissecting opinion to it and it's going
to be like that every single week they
have these
every single sunday it's become part of
beverly hills you don't even go to
beverly hills anymore it's got to be
killing business
you know business is horrible to start
with in beverly hills but why would you
want to go down to a restaurant one of
the nice hotels or have brunch or
anything when that's going on
because it's going to be it's a melee
every single week down there
ladies and gentlemen welcome to joe
biden's america there it is right there
oh no hon we're still trump's still the
president right now that that's what's
okay
we're still in trump territory this is
scary my friend had this this is how
divided the country is right now is that
you can't even just go have a peaceful
rally we're going to fist fight
because you want to show yourself can i
give a dark twist to this i'm going to
give you a dark twist
the freddy krueger you're the exercise
let's give the well i'm going to give
you a
crazy twist to this and tell me what you
think about this um
which side has more money republicans or
democrats
the party no no no the voters which side
has more money
well the democrats have more people so
volume they might
i'll say republicans i'll take a guess
okay well maybe let me ask the question
a different way
okay which side's unemployment is higher
democrat left which side that's a trick
question
which side has more people unemployed
democrats or republicans
i don't know you really say i don't know
i don't know can you actually pull that
number up you actually say you don't
know
i don't know you say you don't know
which side has more democrats
or unemployed answers okay uh which
which
side would like to raise taxes and tax
the rich
people obviously the left or the right
the left okay
which side historically in the last
few elections has uh is willing to
protest and riot and loot and get pretty
ugly about it
which side which side left or the right
both you're going to say evenly i'll say
both sides right
no no you got to say which one's more
than the other the left
okay fair enough and this is coming from
somebody that is a liberal you're not a
left
you're liberal you're center left you
are you are not uh
moderate moderate left no question about
it i will absolutely agree with that i'm
with you all
all my friends out there now he's a
freaking socialist now
you wouldn't have the million dollars
that you have if you don't have the
money that you have today if you if you
were so
adam's a very independent worker he
comes in here not the first but he's the
last
that's we can say because he is in miami
time but but here's the part
the part that makes me think is the
following there are those that know how
to lose
there are those that don't know how to
lose okay what do i mean by this
those who know how to lose it's a very
difficult thing to learn to learn how to
lose
when you lose you got to go out there
and say i lost it's very annoying it's
public it's humiliating
no one likes it no matter who you are
it's painful
you have to go home to your kids you
have to go to go home to your wife to
your spouse
and all the haters that you were trying
to prove wrong
they're all going to come out of this
opportunity i
told you so i knew he was going to fail
i knew he was a loser you have to put up
with that and that noise is going to
last a few months
till the next time you go around in
sports you have one shot every 12 months
he doesn't have it lebron's you you ask
him give him a dollar and he asks for a
change he'll give you three quarters
back
right he won't give you four quarters
because he couldn't win back in the days
do you remember that remember that line
yeah okay so
until it came to the heat till they came
to the eats and then dwyane wade
bailed him out right so so so you go you
go
and you go and hear these stories and
then here's what you think about
when obama was a president how many
riots did you see
a lot of rights why not if somebody was
to ride wouldn't be the opposition
how come we didn't have a lot of rights
record-breaking deport
i mean we had more people getting
deported than ever before you know
reagan gave three million people amnesty
obama said he's going to give amnesty
never happened
so many mexicans and latinos love reagan
because they got amnesty from reagan
what happened with obama never got it
how come there was no protesting and
riots
do you think our country was as divisive
as it was now
no if not more do you think it was more
divided in
2008 let me ask you a question how do
you know we're divided
who's telling you we're divided i mean
i'm just looking at what i see
but whose images the point is you think
it's divided because what the damn tv is
telling you that we are divided who the
hell is the tv
you're saying the media is hyping it up
of course if
if you and i went out to dinner with
50 democrats 50 republicans whoever it
is with our friends
we're gonna have a good time we're
kidding we're gonna have a great time or
you go to a sporting event
in the stands i'm in chicago when i'm in
chicago i love going to chicago because
in chicago at a bar
i like going to a chicago bar at 11
o'clock 12 o'clock
you can have a drink have a great
conversation have debate about sports
because they love debating their sports
and they love debating politics and
you'll have the greatest debate heated
debate
and you leave hugging a guy yeah they're
bears in chicago you leave hugging it's
like oh my gosh john
you know i feel like i've known you for
years you give a hug and you leave screw
you and screw you
up but the way the media is painting it
out
totally so damn so the reason why i'm
giving this point is because you said
something
you said america welcome to biden's
america oh no
it still trumps america they have to
paint
that during trump there's so much
division
that it's because of trump and people
buy it how come we didn't have this kind
of division on the
obama side because the media is
controlled on one side
and the right doesn't riot the way the
left rights
and that's a fact whether you're like
you know i'm i've been a registered
independent for god knows how long now
and that's a fact to see that you don't
see that much
protesting rioting on the right nowhere
near as you see it on the right as you
see it on the left
so they have to paint the picture as
look what a terrible job trump is doing
today
and unfortunately that's going to work
with certain people
that's going to work with a few people
maybe that'll flip a few people
but come november 3rd i don't know
what's going to happen